so hello everybody i am very excited to
be
here with eugene voroleskin uh
eugene is in many people that i've
talked to many authors christian authors
that are here in north america or in
europe
he is really seen as paving the way for
the future of storytelling the future of
christian storytelling
his book loris has made a massive impact
on anybody who is
attentive to culture and also to
like i said christian narrative and how
it is possible to tell stories
today um and so i'm very excited to
look at his book because many of his
themes
connect with my themes this idea of the
edge of the world the notion of a
universal history
all of these things we will be exploring
together in this conversation
and so eugene thank you so much for
taking time to speak to me from russia
right now
thank you very much jonathan for your
invitation
and so the the novel loris is really
amazing it's it's really is an amer
amazing story and
it connects both this ancient vision of
reality
but it also seems to at least in some
aspect it seems to be
talking about working out through the
difficulties of postmodern society
so we can see these images at the outset
of the novel where the main character
is made aware of these geographic limits
of the world
these monsters the sinocephaly the
dog-headed monsters saint christopher
we also hear of the voyages of alexander
all of these references set up a
narrative uh the narrative
as an exploration of the limit and so
the context is not just this idea of
this limit in space but also in time
because the whole book is layered
through this idea
of the end of the world or the different
ends of the world that layer themselves
on top of each other
and whether we see this in this
prophetic vision
whether it's the facing of death but
also even in the narrative elements
itself
we see a breakdown of coherence of which
the main character goes through himself
so this breakdown in in a linear way of
speaking even
goes as far as using anachronisms in the
story where you see things impossible
things coming from the future from the
past melding together
in the same moments and so all of this
really
struck me tremendously about the book
and it made me curious
about how you feel that loris is not
just dealing with something which
happens
you know in the late middle ages in
russia but also dealing with our current
cultural moment uh
well thank you very much for your good
words about my novel
in your question you rightly speak about
the limited space and time about the
borders
and the border place
a certain i would say very important
role in my
novel uh here so we recall we can recall
another concept that is associated with
finitude
actually this concept calls border
and finitude is a border
and the border is not only what
separates
the border is also
something that indicates interaction
because
it is possible to
to interact only with a person or
with a country or with the culture that
is near
you that is in direct contact with you
and uh if we talk about the current
state
of the world then we can
then it has come to the point where
boredom's
borders are disappearing between states
between people
so at first the first look
that is there is nothing wrong in this
but if you will look more closely
on this problem with the loss of
boundaries
differences disappear differences
between cultures
between people between individuals
and it was
[Music]
but actually this stage that
coronavirus pandemic emerged
you know pandemics have actually
occurred before
it is known but the world has never been
completely closed
i have a strange feeling that
the current pandemic has been used by
the world
to rebuild borders i don't think that it
is a conscious process
rather it is a collective unconscious
and it is a great problem
but uh i
try to try to say about it in a few
uh in a few words
and so maybe you will ask
more about on this problem but what i
want uh to say i will come back to my
novel um the russian thinker
mikhail called the space
time system a chronoto
my characters
they transcend both space and time
it is funny but one of my students a
girl
she whittily said that
in this sense laura's is a chronotoplast
because my
protagonists they do with
space and time what do they want
they try to destroy
both of them
but they overcome boundaries for
universal
universal unific not for
universal unification
but they overcome them
metaphysically that is
they go whereas there is neither space
nor
time and in this
quite overcoming of borders
[Applause]
differs from the overcoming which we
call globalization
yeah it's in loris it's very interesting
because you seem to juxtapose
on the one hand a confusion there's a
sense
in some places where there's a confusion
of linearity
and there's a confusion of space and
time
but the character seems to be moving
towards exactly this
transcendence which you speak of
there there's a moment as if it always
almost feels like he is
he is losing himself in those moments
where his memory is broken and he
he had this injury and but then he comes
out
of of that moment and then moves towards
a place where
he sends he seems to transcend it but
even on the on the outside sometimes
that transcendence doesn't appear uh
how can i say this externally as easily
as we would want it to
and so the last moment of the main
character you know his death
and the way that he has to be treated it
might seem
like he is losing himself but ultimately
if you followed the arc of the character
there he is actually moving into that
transcendent zone at least that is how i
i saw the the movement of the character
you see the medieval people
they had more complicated relations with
the
time and
and eternity than we have
they actually they lived
that time lifetime was not so long
40 years 50 years
we have exceptions of course but still
it was not as long
as now but still
their lives were rather long why
because in each fragment of their life
they had a direct call to the heaven
to the place where
doesn't exist time or space
and they
measured themselves
not with
with such terms as
here and now
but they thought about eternity
and that is and the time was not so busy
as
now uh you know in uh
early um middle ages
people they didn't use even a
clock it was enough
to see the position of the sun
and it was really enough
and the life was quiet
and in this life
in the center of the personal life was
a god with
eternity and in the center in the center
of the social life
was a monastery monster was
so uh in russia maybe in the west it was
a little bit
another situation but in russia
monastery was the university's school
was academy of sciences and
so on and so forth
and this all the things they
made the attitude towards time
and space rather specific
and i would say
that we have
a good example of the right attitude
towards the time
yeah we have i mean i think as as
christians today especially as orthodox
christians we still
find an image of that in liturgical time
where we see in the way in which time is
treated
within the liturgy and how we have this
this kind of movement and apex towards
you know the union of heaven and earth
the a the union with the angels and
also even the uh the again and again
of prayers of this this cycle of prayers
which which starts and ends and starts
and ends
we get a sense of this different uh this
different perception and participation
in time that
infused the middle ages yes in lawrence
i write
about this
interesting time of
of christianity because uh so it is an
uh common thing it is known that um
the time in pagan societies or
uh so
so this time is
not linear but it is a circle
uh and that is why uh
it was possible to hear this famous
phrase
antic phrase that his history is
a teacher of
of the life
and why it was so because
[Music]
as the people
of those times considered considered
the similar
circumstances they
gave similar
results and it was possible to live in
this circle
uh judeo-christian
uh history is a linear history it is
it is a time excuse me this
it is a historical time it is the time
that had
its beginning uh history
that had its beginning and was
uh no and is
always waiting uh for its uh
uh last day uh and uh
so but uh christian
history is if i would
find if i would
speak about the symbol of this history
maybe it is
[Music]
uh
[Music]
spiral yes because the
same history has its
rhymes uh and
all the uh or not all maybe the most
important things uh they come back but
they come back
in another uh drastic
in another with another face
you know this famous
[Music]
topological exege exaggerates
of the church father's
topology tupus and anti-turpos
uh christ as a new adam
um mary uh
as a new eve and so on
uh on the one hand this time
was uh had its direction
from the uh beginning to the end
on the other hand uh it was um
eternity dimension uh
the circle and
this
this collaborating so to say
of the
time and eternity
it is a characteristic
the most maybe
essential characteristic of the uh
christian time and history yes
i think i i was very happy that you used
the image of the spiral
because i really also think that very
much so
even looking at the final image
in the book of revelation the image of
the new jerusalem
we see that it contains the guardian of
eden inside
its own resolution and so it is both a
return to the beginning
but also a transformation of that
beginning into something completely new
and so you do have this sense that it's
it turns but it also
it's always going up let's say into god
um
and so that that is definitely something
if you remember in laros i have
such as uh fragment uh all the
uh try uh tries to explain
what does it mean christian time and he
makes
uh circles uh around the monastery
and uh then
so the first circle was he was walking
the second third he was flying not very
high but still
it was enough to make laura sure
that the time is a spiral
and so this this part yes they
so this monk says to laura's
uh you see now i'm flying not very high
but no it's enough
well that comment brings me to my second
big uh
question uh so which is that
one of the most striking aspects in
loras
is how the book embraces a form of
realism
the type of realism that we find in all
the great
russian novels but also there is
injected
into it something which i can only call
this magical
aspect you know and the example you gave
is one of them there are also wonderful
examples
of uh the holy fools who walk on water
and there are many other miracles which
are happening um and this is something
which you know
let's say historically for russian
novels we would find in
in someone like bulgakov um but in
bulgakov's work in master and margarita
for example
these fantastical elements they'd serve
a
strange solipsistic fantasy you know
somewhat like in the tradition of the
surrealists or the late
uh the late 19th century symbolist but
in your work
all of this seems to be integrated in a
very different way
as a movement towards what many of us
have been thinking about what we call
something like a christian
re-enchantment of the world
and so i was curious is as modernity as
this the modern
thrust reaches its twilight what
possibilities do you see for such
a christian re-enchantment of the world
well as for the mythology in my novel
it follows not a modern view of things
but
medieval one
mythology is useful when something meets
to make up for the lack of real
knowledge
you know moses describes the creation
of the world and as a process that
developed over
six days you must
admit that it would be strange if the
people of that time
would describe the creation of the world
and man
in terms of geophysics or genetics
gradually knowledge is
concrete concretized taking the form of
scientific knowledge but
this does not make any significant
changes in the picture
of the world
a fragment i would
[Music]
i would remember a fragment of my last
novel the justification of
the island it will be published
i hope later in english
so there
it is a rather
strange dialogue between
between uh a medieval medieval
man uh and modern uh
film director interesting and
yes and they speak about the different
consciousness about different
[Music]
notion of the world creation and
everything that surrounds us and um
he and film director asks this medieval
man uh
he shows him uh old man script where
[Music]
so i have forgotten this word in english
something that flies from this
heaven like a spaceship it's all right
material a meteorite yes okay yeah
meteorite and
he says you see
it was um
the painter not painter so maybe
a man who wrote this manuscript
the author uh tried to
so he uh painted uh this meteorite
as a snake as a dragon uh
and he said uh now we understand what
does it
mean this meteorite
what does it consist of and so on
and you can deny that
for your contemporaries it was a snake
he said he asked
your contemporaries called a meteorite
snake a snake and
medieval uh protagonist
answers yes i can't deny it is
clear they called its
dragon and film director asks
or and now
what you can say about our days he said
now they called snake material
that's wonderful
that's wonder it's it's wonderful
because
i i myself have felt also that the
modern
categorizations are have become so
um so so pointed
that it makes it impossible for people
today
or very difficult for people today to
understand
ancient ways of understanding or ancient
ways of categorizing
a category especially a category like
dragon
if you try to reduce that to a
a let's say a measurable phenomena that
you can categorize with biology
is completely missing the point of of
even the way the dragon
functioned in middle medieval thinking
uh and so it
it's almost like it's really two worlds
that that don't touch each other
very difficultly touch each other yes
and
their metaphorical language maybe they
were not
for awareness that it was so
metaphorical
but uh this language actually
it gives no possibility to say that
these people were primitive
or uh actually
the main things uh were
uh known uh in medieval ages
and now uh or unknown uh
so we know the details
uh but uh the whole we don't know and
i fear that we will never know it uh
uh not never i mean
never in this uh in the on the earth
it will come a day if god will
he will show and tell us how it was
but not here i suppose exactly
um okay so i'm going to move on to my
next big question
uh which is really one of the things
which
fascinated me when reading loras and so
during what people call the middle ages
there was a universal history consensus
we could call it
it was a bringing together of different
elements
which included the bible christian
legends
but also included uh
ancient mythological patterns like the
the trojan war or alexander the great
so for example several texts you know
from the the aeneid to the
eddas the arthurian cycles they all see
their origins
in troy uh gog and magog are found
in alexander's romance muslims saw
themselves as descendants of ishmael
etc etc hungarians saw themselves as
descendants of
nimrod so there are many more examples
of course and
all of this culminates in text that we
find
something like dante's comedy for
example where he tries to trace this
mythological unity of all the ancient
stories
brought together with a biblical one so
this mythological unity
has been progressively destroyed by
scholars uh through
different techniques uh whether it's
trying to find pagan
to look only at the pagan versions of
stories which were
ultimately brought into christianity uh
whether it is by using just historical
techniques to show that this or this
fact is not possible
but there is still a deep desire for
this kind of unity of story
um and so we see this kind of
interconnected legendarium or
mythological world
uh being revived in people like tolkien
and we see it in many many other popular
popular franchises like star wars or
marvel comics and
you know a harry potter all of these
these stories which are very popular
present us a kind of unified
mythological story
and so in loris you allude to this
many times you you kind of bring it you
you bring it to the fore uh into the
story at these illusions to
to alexander you know to these mythical
uh creatures on the edge of the world
and so i was wondering what you thought
what kind of use you think these
legends that have been mainly forgotten
by many people but are still there
uh what use they can be for us today is
it possible to recover
some of this christian mythology for our
time
thank you uh as i
was hearing you um i thought about my
translator my american translator
lisa hayden she's a genius translator
and so your questions
show me how uh how
[Music]
sophisticated she made this translation
and
how deep uh he
came in in into the text or
and how deep she is
in this interacting of cultures and
traditions
it is really a very important question
because it shows us
many things among them
that christianity is not a futuristic
futuristical futuristic religion
it never pretended to come from nothing
and it
not only fought against the previous
religious skulls
but also incorporated
this is how for example christopher
ascend with the dogs had
synocopholis arose he went back from
he went back to the egyptian jackal god
anubis and this is how
he was portrayed in russia and say in
ireland why because ireland
had direct connections to egyptian
monasticism and
[Music]
by the way with it it was amazing
history of this
painting uh it was um
very interesting uh history
up to the 18th century in russia
christopher
was with the go with the dog's
head but metropolitan
[Music]
in the 18th century he interrupted this
tradition
and he said that instead of dog's head
one must paint the head
of the murder demeters
and as his arguments uh
he had a wonderful argument he knocked
everybody uh with it he said that
the life of christopher said that
[Music]
breast prostitutes wanted
to
[Music]
somehow to to seduce him
to him but uh metropolitan garcinia
writes
that if he would be with the dog's hand
no one prostitute would come to him
i suppose that he underestimate these
women
so dogs had it is not the worst that
they have seen in their lives uh and
but the story was rather funny
uh and uh what else uh
the pagan fest for example of uh
solstice
uh gave way to the christian feast of
the john the baptist
and christianity skillfully dealt with
pagan mythology
so the byzantine chronicle of john
malala
tries to synchronize the biblical
biblical tradition with
ancient mythology to do this he uses
so-called
fjmer method of
[Music]
so what uh according to the chronicle
um uh he he turns that
it turns out that chronos is one of the
sons of noah
and the father of the earth
and it was the direct line
from adam
why was it so no because
uh from the christian point of view
it was only one universal history
and no one history could exist in
addition
so to say uh if
there is only one history uh
one had the two ways to react
uh or according to psalm consider
consider
the gods of pagans demons
demons demons or and
uh to fight against them
or uh in incorporate them
and christianity used both
methods and
[Music]
what is interesting is that
it was from that point of view
it was a progressive thing why
because um
they this uh incorporation
helped to
to establish christianity uh
and the chronicles who integrated
mythology into christian
history spoke with yesterday's pagans
in their language and
here you can also recall the first
russian chronicle
the tale of bygone years
this chronicle uh demonstrates a
special attention to angels why
because it was it was a way of slowly
uh transitioning from politics into
monarchies
uh that is why they were so attentive
to angels and so on and so forth there
are many many
uh and other examples of
this collaboration that was rather
useful i would say
and do you think that do you think that
exploring these connections can be
useful to us
uh today in this post post-christian
type of world oh
it is a difficult question now when
no neo paganism has become becoming
popular
uh when we are overwhelmed by a new
mythology in literature and
art uh access
i says the situation in a completely
different way
at the beginning of christianity this
was justified
but after the establishment of
christianity
i see no justification for it
everything was already said we know
it from christ
he told us all this
only justification i see
is to view mythology as a special
metaphorical language uh as to
consider it as the language of poetry
really it is useful and nice i like
this pieces of art
that use mythology but
in this case we must clear clearly
separate poetry from the religion
and not see any metaphorical
metaphysics behind it
have you thought a bit about because
here in
let's say in um in the in north america
and in europe
uh jr tolkien has been a very large
influence
even in terms of people converting to
eastern orthodoxy for some reason
um he tried to create a form
of let's say almost a form
of mythological structure which was not
like you said it
it was a poetry in the sense it was
fiction but it was trying to show
you know it was trying to show the
coherence of the world through a
fantastical lens
uh in a way that could be that was
palatable
for people today in a way that people
could could connect to people's
imaginary
um and so i don't know if you've thought
a little bit about that type of approach
in terms of
art creation you know
tolkien or for example
[Music]
this long legend about harry potter
it is
something uh something
uh strange because uh
as you know tolkien was forgotten
he was not so popular
after his death it is uncomparable with
with the modern admiration of
him the question lies not in tolkien
the question lies in us so
some pieces of art are forgotten for
centuries
but suddenly they have
unexpected resonance with
modern problems with modern point of
view
and they are
exhibited so to say
i i fear that it is not the proper word
yeah yeah they're dug up they're brought
back yeah
yes and they
are discovered for the second time even
for the first time
now it is
time uh you know now really as you said
uh we live in to my pretty mostly
post-christian society
uh and but
[Music]
human being can
come live without metaphysics
and so
we differ from our uh brothers animals
uh in this way so
we need uh uh we need
god we need uh
we need to explain
somehow our soul the phenomenon of
soul of um
thinking and so on and uh
god uh is no more in the center of
the uh birth of the life of
personality uh nothing
is not in the center of society
and but this great wish
uh to another dimension
that is everybody
feel this dimension not everybody
can speak about it and
so express their feelings but they fail
and they
find they discover for their
[Applause]
discover for them
[Music]
some sort of metaphysics but this
metaphysics
is not very
high one it is uh
so christian in if we'll speak
just uh about ideas not not about sacral
things uh if we'll take
a great system of christian christian
philosophy
about the if you speak about the harmony
harmony of
[Music]
christianity and christian ideas
and when we will speak about harry
potter
so these are different things i have
nothing against
such tales so maybe for somebody
it is a first step to another dimension
it could be but
the matter is that the
[Music]
this great thirst
this great wish uh for
for something that not from is not from
here uh pushes
the people to this uh
strange type of metaphysics
that was uh
that characterized mankind uh
before christianity many many centuries
ago
it's strange and a little bit funny
a little bit funny indeed and so
the difficulty one of the difficulties
we have
here i think is that much of the art
which is considered explicitly christian
for our culture is deeply mediocre
the music the novels the
there is there is something which
there's a
much of the art which considers itself
explicitly christian has a bad
smell it just it's there's something
propagandistic about it there's
something uh
superficial about its metaphysics about
its approach and so
what is the advice that you would have
to give to
aspiring artists who want to use
their faith or their worldview in their
artwork but they struggle to do so in a
way that is
profound uh
i remember the expression
of
my beloved writer
joseph pater brown
chester gilbert kate chesterton he was a
wonderful
thinker uh
he was not at all dull have had a
wonderful humor sense and
and once he said that
what lacks christianity is to be of
chinese or japanese
origin or something like this or from
uh from the far east
yes he said that for
he said he spoke about the english
society of
his time but he said christian
christianity is too too much
at home here and
that is why people they want
to to if they have water as i for
example here
if they have water they don't uh drink
they don't want to drink it is so easy
to to
drink water the stands near you uh
it is better to
i don't know to to go to the restaurant
uh and to buy the
identical glass of water and
to drink it with another feeling
yes and
maybe people
must be enough wise to
[Music]
to discover in old
uh and maybe forgotten
things
the new
[Music]
new ideas new because
bible
it is a book that has
everything uh if you want
uh to uh you can laugh
you can cry reading the bible
i know i knew i had a colleague in
germany he was a
great specialist on the bible
and he
as he finished his uh
lectures he was
almost in despair because his students
were rather so they were sleeping
and but the last his sentence was
my dear read the bible it is more
exciting than harry potter
that is definitely something which at
least
around me all of a sudden i feel people
are getting more excited a little bit
about scripture
again and i think that the return to
narrative
is part of it because one of the the
disservices
that has been given to us by modern
scholars
is that they've sucked the story out of
scripture
they've they've reduced it to textual
analysis
source analysis and all these extremely
technical
ways of seeing scripture and they
have forgotten or ignored the power of
typological
reading and the kind of narrative
parallels that you can make when you
read scripture
in that way um but i feel like
with even with post-modernism somehow
that this type of reading is now
possible again and the the exploring the
strange stories and judges and
all the very weird elements of scripture
is maybe a way for people to
rediscover the how wonderful and strange
the scripture really is
yes from time to time i
read the scripture and
as a writer i can't understand
how nice is it as
[Applause]
for example this story with
with 10 ill men that were
healed by christ and
his question that is actually not a
question
he said were
not the 10 of
the 10 healed and where are
9 he knows of course but
this expression
through the question it is so strong
literally uh or
for example uh
i don't know it in english but in
old church slavonic or in russian this
um
about naboo nebuchadnezzar
nasser this wonderful
phrase you was uh
wait uh on the um
how it will be in english uh the
thing where you can wait uh the balance
yeah like on the balance and it was
weighed under balance
[Music]
by on a scale on a scale was the skill
of the god and you was found
very light yes it is incredibly good
yeah and the the stories of
nebuchadnezzar becoming an
animal in the field
those stories are astounding they're
they're
something that could be in your novel
loris i think
yes and uh you know
in the bible you can find about the love
solomon you can find
you can find actually a key to the
world history world history is not as
marxist
say so that
some events they
provocate another events they provocate
the struggle of the club of classes and
so on
[Music]
it is a time to gather stones
and the time to uh
help me uh to
push you away right right right yeah
yeah
to to gather and to to yes and uh
actually history is uh
uh actually his history uh is
just
[Music]
something that has its rhythms as a wave
nobody knows why this wave comes uh
and how to uh
how to predict big waves
and so on and as our writer liskov
he wrote nobody knows
about each man what thinks about him
god and one
monk told me a good joke
about a priest and
a driver or bus driver
they after the death they met each other
in the paradise
and as
the priest saw the driver he was a
drunkard
and drove his bus on serpentine
and suddenly he sees him in paradise and
he asks god
tell me please i
many for many decades i
spoke to my
brothers and sisters i i told so many
good words and he drunk
all this time and he
he put in questions the lives
of his of the people that were sitting
in the bus
and he's also here why and god answered
him
uh so all you during
all your speeches uh everybody was
sleeping
but if this man came into came to
serpentine with his bus all the people
were praying
that's so wonderful that's a wonderful
it's a wonderful joke and it
it also shows us as you said that the
the secret patterns that are hidden in
us
are not sometimes they're they're not as
easily discernible as we would
as we would want and and certain certain
action
have con let's say have opposite effects
that end up bringing everything
nonetheless even if it looks
dangerous at the moment nobody knows the
ways of
god and his creatures
so eugene thank you so much for your
time i really
i really appreciate our discussion for
you making time out for me
late on uh on an evening uh for you
we're definitely looking forward to your
your future novel if
if it will be translated into english
just the little hint that you gave
is already making me want to uh to read
it and so i really appreciate
i i speak also on behalf of of so many
uh christian artists that sometimes feel
hopeless
really really hopeless in terms of the
capacity to tell
stories that are vibrant and alive and
so i feel like you have given us
some keys and some some some examples to
to follow and to emulate so thank you so
much thank you very much and
i will i would like to send my love to
my
readers and non-readers
and future readers and future readers
and to express my love to america and
american people
thank you very much thanks